okay hello everyone welcome to another
episode of history of science and
technology q a
and uh i see there are a bunch of
questions here saved up i'm happy to
talk about
either things that i've been directly
involved in or things that i've studied
for measure or another
um
gosh a lot of interesting things here
all right let's jump into the first one
from matt here what is the history of
the notion of infinity in mathematics
and science in general
interesting question
you know
back
so
infinity
what might it be it's like you count
numbers and you just keep counting
forever what do you get to
who first asked that question
well i'm not sure but we can say a few
things about it
so for example in antiquity
there were numbers that were
you know there was a notation for
numbers in the in the greek notation for
numbers numbers were represented by
lessons of the alphabet not a
particularly good design decision when
you change your alphabet your numbers
are all you know skew and you have to
leave letters in your alphabet that went
out of circulation for words but you
leave them in there for numbers happened
to sampy and diegamer in greek for
example
um but there was sort of a notation for
numbers for explicit numbers
that notation got quite extended for
example archimedes pretty famously wrote
uh a thing called the sand reckoner
where he was asking the question how
many grains of sand are there in the
world and actually how many grains of
sand would fit in the universe
it's kind of interesting that archimedes
in in whatever
100 bc or so
was asking
that kind of question
and he had to invent a notation for
bigger and bigger and bigger numbers
and and his estimate for grains of sand
in the universe he thought well maybe
the universe is about oh i think he had
like twice the size of the um the
orbital the distance from the earth to
the sun which he had some big idea about
and you know he imagine you fill that up
with grains of sand how many do you get
and uh
that was so he was dealing with very big
numbers but i don't think he had the
idea of infinity the idea that there's a
number that is the number that would be
the thing you get by sort of counting
forever
i'm not sure when that notion really
came in i mean we can talk about when
other ideas about numbers came in the
idea of zero
was also something that came in quite
late
um that's something where there were
precursors maybe in antiquity there were
sort of indications in indian work and
so on that of some notion of zero the
number that isn't there so to speak
but even but negative numbers were also
not
something that people really talked
about it's like why would you want a
negative number why would you want to
explicitly talk about
having taken the numbers away so to
speak
i think
a strange thing is that in around 1 500
when cardano was working on
the solution of the cubic equation
the casus irreducible s the
the irreducible case of the cubic
equation
um
is a case where you pretty much are
forced into both negative numbers
and complex numbers
and strangely it seems that both of
those concepts kind of came in around
the same time that that was a place
where you really had to think seriously
about negative numbers
when you also had to think seriously
about complex numbers about the square
root of minus one and so on and it's
strange that negative numbers took so
long to become kind of mainstream kind
of mathematical concepts
you would have thought when you know
people were like luca pacioli in the
1400s coming up with you know uh or
codifying double entry bookkeeping for
accounting
that you might have said well gosh you
know surely there were negative numbers
there and there were there was a
separate column or you know what we now
do numbers with parentheses things like
that but in a sense
i suppose you could think about sort of
the double entry bookkeeping mechanism
as avoiding the needs to actually pick
up a negative number and say here's this
negative number it's in some column in
the um and now we're i'm i'm i'm
reaching the embarrassment point of
realizing that that uh in all the time
i've done business kinds of things that
have been computerized accounts and i
don't get to see the um uh the kind of
um the original luca pacioli style dummy
bookkeeping with columns and so on
i remember when i was a kid people had
these these and actually i've seen them
for historical figures like i looked at
babbage's account books and they indeed
have these multi-column entries for
things um i have to admit i'm not sure i
completely know how to read those
um but in any case that was i think a
way of avoiding the need for an explicit
pick it up and say it's a negative
number thing in modern you know in
accounting kinds of things there will be
numbers in parentheses and so on today
uh straight interestingly different from
our usual notation in mathematical kinds
of things by putting a minus sign in
front of the number
but
that's not answering the question about
infinity when did infinity really
uh sort of get seriously talked about i
think
i'm guessing that it wasn't until the
1800s but i'm not absolutely sure
i think that oh actually no here's a
place where it will have gotten talked
about the concept of infinite series
that was something that was
i don't think
i i think people
had
looked at that a bit um
maybe the bernoullis had looked at that
1600s kind of time frame but the idea
that you would have a sum of terms and
you would sum it to infinity like a sum
of one over one squared plus one over
two squared plus one over three squared
etc summing that to infinity and getting
in that particular case pi squared over
six the notion that you would do that
for an infinite number of terms that was
a notion that certainly if it hadn't
really uh
developed well in the 1600s it was
something that was developing then i
remember when um
for leibniz
um
leibniz uh when he wanted to learn math
he was sort of uh sent
he was on paris on a sort of diplomatic
mission for his day job of of doing kind
of um
uh what would be the modern analog he
was kind of a um
uh some sort of mixture of ambassador
and um think tank person
for the dukes of hanover and so on in
what's now germany
um and uh
he um when he went to paris
he um
uh paris was sort of a hotbed of
mathematical this is we're now talking
the um
the 16
uh
60s that 1660s to 1670s i think
um
he um
uh hotbed was sort of a paris was kind
of a hotbed of mathematical work at that
time
um leibniz went there
and who was it
oh my gosh um
french mathematician at the time
not for matt but somebody in that orbit
uh basically told leibniz
if you want to come talk to me about
math prove that you're worthy by showing
how to sum some infinite series which
leibniz was able to do so i think by
that time the notion of infinite series
was definitely a thing so the idea of
there would be an infinite number of
terms that you had to add up that was a
place but now the idea that
uh clearly when we're talking about for
example zero
the the notion of i don't have any
cows or something that had been a notion
for a long time but the idea of an
explicit notation
for zero cows that was a much later
construct and i'm sort of guessing that
the same is true of infinite series now
i'm thinking in the 1700s euler for
example did a lot of work with infant
series and i'm pretty sure he had a
notation for that and i'm pretty sure
this is obviously an easy thing to look
up when the notation for infinity came
in but i think that um i'm sort of
guessing that euler already had that
euler was a big one for for various
kinds of notations i mean he was the one
who adopted the the pie notation for
example that was originally invented by
a welsh chapter called jones um but uh
euler was sort of famous for using the
pi notation
and and the e notation which doesn't
stand for euler it stands for the
exponential constant and so on
but in terms of of sort of the so using
infinity
series i think that came in quite early
the notion of infinity as the thing you
get by counting forever
um i think that
was something that was uh sort of being
talked about a bunch in the 1800s in
connection particularly with the
definition of real numbers um the idea
that one could have these sort of
infinitely finely uh gradated numbers
where you have an infinite number of
digits kind of almost the same notion as
the infinite series notion an infinite
number of digits and you're sort of
having these infinite processes going
and trying to home in on on that precise
real number whether it's cushy sequences
or dedicated cuts these are both sort of
infinite progressions a little bit like
the infinite series idea but i would say
that the notion of infinity is kind of a
thing that you just sort of uh
um you know bat around um
is is very much a gorg cantor type
notion from the 1870s 1880s kind of time
frame now kanto who was originally
working on infinite series he was
interested in trigonometric series he
was interested in the question of when
do series of sums of sines and cosines
and things when do they converge when do
they not converge what are the sets of
parameter values for which they converge
those kinds of things he found that was
extremely complicated
and in the process of thinking about
that
came up with set theory and came up with
transfinite numbers and transfinite
numbers are a much finer gradation of
the notion of infinity i mean there's
the idea you know you count all the
integers and then you get to lowercase
omega
as the the first
um uh transfinite ordinal you can ask
about omega plus one omega plus two
omega to the omega omega to the omega
the omega and eventually get to sort of
another level epsilon zero and then you
keep going and what kanto did was to
make sort of a
a a generalized arithmetic that
represented these transfinite numbers
where you could have statements like you
know one plus omega is the same as omega
those are equal omega plus one is not
the same as omega omega plus one is
strictly greater than omega those kinds
of things
and
the um
uh and a lot of that became quite funky
because
things like the commutative rule that x
plus y is equal to y plus x is no longer
true for transfinite numbers all sorts
of other things that would normally be
true about numbers like you know given a
number there's an integer and maybe you
can write it out in different ways but
it's always the same integer
how do you make a sort of a normal form
for a number that's a non-trivial thing
in the case of kanto's transfinite
numbers
and but by the time kantor was talking
about those kinds of things the notion
of infinity had definitely landed
and in set theory the big thing that
makes set theory non-trivial is the idea
that you can have an infinite set of
objects
and this whole lots of questions about
given that there are two infinite sets
can there always be a correspondence
between the elements in one set and
another set all these kinds of things
that led to the kind of thinking about
about infinity in axiomatic terms
i mean before that time you know i don't
think euclid uh when he was making up
the sort of exomatic system for geometry
um
in in uh
whatever 100 something bc
um
that was that was not a kind of thing
that he was talking about there he would
talk about things like oh they're
actually there's another case now that i
think about it
he he had the notion of there an
infinite number of primes
there's never a largest prime i don't
know exactly how he said that
i he definitely wasn't talking about i
mean it's just like i'm sure euclid was
was well aware of the fact that there
wasn't ever a largest number clearly he
knew that by the time he was also
talking about there's never a largest
brine
but i think that that
was not something where one kind of
picked up this notion of infinity in
that way just to give you an example of
how one doesn't necessarily pick up the
notion of infinity even today
when we're dealing with computation
and we ask about
an infinite data structure that's
something not well understood even today
we can ask about you know an infinite
tree we can imagine how that works but
let's say we have a program and we
imagine running the program forever and
the program is producing some data
structure it can produce this
complicated thing we don't have a good
characterization of that thing we can
perhaps use trans-finite numbers to try
and give some indication of what's going
on we don't have a good theory of that
even today
and but but coming back to the the 1800s
and and so on i think the thing that
really happened then was the idea that
sort of infinity was a thing you could
pick up that was something that cancer
really introduced and you could do
things with it and you could have axioms
that would say things were true about
infinity
and i think
in a sense that was the um
that was the time when people started to
be i would say comfortable in in talking
about infinity as a mathematical kind of
construct it's a slippery construct as
kantor showed because you might say
there's just one infinity like in
wolfram language for example if you type
one over zero you get the symbol
infinity um actually you get um let's
see in that particular case you probably
get complex infinity because infinity is
a slippery thing it's like what infinity
do you mean you mean the infinity that
you get by counting up all the integers
and just keeping on going like kanto
talked about with ordinal numbers or do
you mean the infinity that somewhere far
out in the complex plane you don't know
what direction you just divide it by
zero and that could have been you know
one plus r
it doesn't make a distinction between 1
plus i divided by 0 and 2 divided by 0
and so on
so
uh
this notion that um but but one thing to
say about infinity
is
the very idea that you need to do proofs
of things
is in a sense a consequence of infinity
or infinitesimals or whatever because if
you're just saying two plus two is four
okay we can pick up two counters another
two counters we can mix them together
and we'll find out we have four counters
any finite computation like that any
finite statement you could just
explicitly do the computation and see
what happens
when you have an infinite number of
things you can't expect to do the
computation and see what happens you
have to have kind of some symbolic
reasoning about what's going on
and the same thing is true with
infinitesimal things and that's in a
sense what led euclid to start trying to
make an axiomatic system for geometry
the idea that you can have a point and
place it anywhere and these points can
be arbitrarily close together and so on
that means that you can't just say well
let me just look at let me explicitly
enumerate all possible geometrical
figures because there will be as we
could now say it an infinite number of
these because these points can be placed
anywhere now in our current theory of
physics we kind of think euclid wasn't
right about that
that there is actually a an underlying
dispute structure to space and to where
points can be placed in some sense or
what the relationship between points can
be but in the perception that euclid had
of how kind of uh mathematical structure
works for him it's like a point could be
put anywhere and so you have to have a
proof
that this geometrical figure works in
exactly this way because you can't
verify that by explicitly enumerating
possible configurations of points and so
on
so i i think that's in a sense that's
the driver for sort of the notion of
wheeling in proof as a a significant
thing
as a necessary thing in mathematics is
the presence of infinity you'll never
actually be able to count there you have
to symbolically prove that fact rather
than as a matter of as an axiomatic
matter rather than
explicitly doing the computation
and needless to say you don't get
something for nothing these sort of
proofs that involve infinity then you
have to sort of regress to say well did
we really get the right axioms and then
you've got a lot of other complexity
there of um of of girdles and
completeness theorem things like that of
even given the underlying set of axioms
there will be proofs that you can never
never do
um that within that that particular set
of axioms there will be things where you
thought you were
you you thought you were talking about
integers and there'd be things that are
true about integers but just given a
particular axiomatic description of
integers you won't be able to reach
those things that you thought were true
about integers and so on so complicated
complicated story but i i would say that
that if you sort of
the notion of an infinite series
infinite sequence of things that seems
to be in a much earlier notion than this
notion of a thing you can pick up and
it's called infinity just like in the
past a thing you can pick up and it's
called xero was something that was
pretty late in the history of of
mathematical thinking now today
there are i would say infinite
computations
are kind of the next frontier of things
you can pick up and talk about as i say
we don't really have a great way to
think about those yet
that's something which in some of the
things that are spinning off from our
physics project and this really adds
structure that i've been studying quite
a bit this notion of an infinite
computation and being able to talk about
that there'll probably be a time
when you know a version of of somebody
doing this in in some number of decades
or more will be saying gosh uh you know
and then there was this notion of the
infinite computation
and the kind of uh the the infinite
computation symbol that isn't an
infinity sign it's something else that
is some notation for infinite
computations and it took a really long
time for people to figure out that that
was useful
and uh you know partly because who would
think infinity would be useful after all
it's just oh you just keep counting
forever whatever why would you have to
pick it up and do something with it same
with infinite computations today um
although i think uh well this will get
us off topic to talk about combinators
and infinite computations there and how
that works and and sort of the
beginnings of of having a formulation
see for example one of the issues is and
this comes up in cantor's work on on
infinity is you've got two infinite
things are they the same thing
in other words
let's say
you've uh you've got this structure it's
been built and it's got an infinite
collection of tentacles
are those
you've got two different ways to build
it
are those things the same just like you
might have numbers which you represent
in terms of square roots and this and
that and the other and the the way you
write down the number looks different
but it may still be the same number and
similarly when you build some data
structure there might be two different
ways to build it you keep going to
infinity and
and then you have to ask the question
are these two things you built the same
and that may be a very non-trivial
question to answer and that's that's the
type of reason why it's difficult to
formulate these things involving
infinity
um
it's a comment here
let's see about the difference between
eternity and
infinity um
yeah there are some interesting issues
there there's there's questions about
sort of an infinite number of things an
infinite distance an infinite time
how do those all relate
for example time
in our theory of physics these days
is the progression of time is the doing
of a computation in which the universe
determines its next state so to speak
and so when we talk about sort of
eternity and infinite time we're really
talking about an infinite progression of
computation in that kind of setup and
that's that is
potentially a different kind of thing
than to say infinitely far away in space
let's say space is represented by some
manifold in mathematics or by some
hypergraph in our theory of physics and
you're saying i've got an infinite one
of those let me go infinitely far away
there that that that is a different kind
of thing from this infinite progression
of computation
uh and and that is yet different again
from things like well let me look at all
the different possible rules that i
could use for the system that's sort of
another kind of infinity at some level
so in this thing we call the ruliad that
i call really i suppose the the um uh
that is this kind of entangled limit of
all possible computations there are
multiple kinds of infinity that all
contribute to the structure of the
ruling ad in the end the ruliad is just
this one thing it is all possible
computations an infinite collection of
possible computations from all possible
initial states another infinity run for
an infinite time
and yes there are interesting
distinctions to be made between these
different kinds of infiniti i mean in
the in the rouliad
those
that there's just this one object that's
sort of infinite in all those directions
but as you start trying to slice it for
sort of human understanding purposes
those different kinds of infinity seem
rather different
um at least for our experience like our
experience of infinite space is
presumably different from our experience
and infinite time and it's different
from my experience of infinite number so
to speak or infinite counting so to
speak
um
okay let's see
uh
well let me try it now there's a
question from aaron here which is
actually rather related to this
can you talk about the history of the
idea of an elementary length
what have people believed about the
smallest possible length and what what
how has that evolved
so
in our current theory of physics
the one we've been well i've been
developing since the 90s but we've been
developing seriously in the last couple
of years there is an elementary length
there are discrete atoms of space
and
the thing that is really most defined is
the elementary time
that is these atoms of space undergo
kind of events updates changes we can
think about sort of atoms of change
being those events that take place to
these atoms of space
and we can then just say well there's a
there's a change that happens to this
atom of space and then there's another
change that happens to it and we can
simply define the elementary time
is
the
is the time between those update events
and that's in a sense the the doing of
one computational step
we can define is the elementary time
because time is the progression of
computation we can say well we measure
these things on a watch or something and
that watch is itself doing computations
to sort of well move its second hand or
whatever the modern watch does
um and
that's there's a set of computations
happening there and we're using those as
kind of the fiducial compensations to
measure the the rate of elapsing of time
and then we can apply that to something
else and we can say in that thing that
we experientially call a second
how many elementary updates were done
maybe it's 10 to 100 we don't know
that's sort of a very very you know very
rickety estimate
um given the elementary time the
elementary length
is basically how far does light get in
elementary time which is to say
that's something that
we can we can sort of think about it as
we've got an instantaneous state of
space and we've got these atoms of space
and they're kind of connected to
neighboring atoms of space and how far
are those connections while they
correspond to an elementary time which
is sort of speed of light times the
elementary dis uh sorry those first one
to elementary length which is speed of
light times the elementary time
so
okay what's the history of this
you know i think in
ancient greek times democritus leukemis
people like this
they kind of thought the world of mate
was made of atoms you know an atom it's
a greek word for an uncuttable thing
they thought it was made of these
discrete elements and the thing that
they had that was pretty pretty
pretty clever was this notion of the
world could be made from lots of
identical copies of the same thing even
though there's so much diversity of
stuff in the world in the end at the
very lowest level it could be made of
identical things that's a very kind of
forward-looking notion
because it's not obvious you know you
see all these different things in the
world really could could have all of
these things to be made of different
configurations of atoms
so that notion existed at that time
i think that the kind of the the way of
thinking about science
was not such that somebody would
seriously have asked how big might those
atoms be for example
uh i
i don't think that was really asked at
that time now now there were things like
zeno's paradoxes which all had to do
with these questions about well well can
you subdivide things infinitely far or
is there a and xenos paradoxes were kind
of like assuming you can subdivide
infinitely far then you get these
strange kinds of things about some that
seem paradoxical but people i think
i don't know
i'm not sure people really put all these
pieces together of you know if the world
is really made of discrete elementary
lengths then we kind of evade zeno's
paradoxes in some funny way but we get
other things i'm not sure that was all
put together
but
for a long time
there was
uh
you know people viewed aristotle and
things like that as being kind of the
definitive scientific treatises and and
they didn't really progress much beyond
that by the 1600s and so on people
were looking further so to speak and and
people like um
you know descartes certainly had things
to say about um uh the sort of the
structure of the universe and whether it
was atomic or not
um i'm not sure
the um
uh again
this question i mean
there was a lot of question about light
you know was light
made of discrete corpuscles or not
um people didn't really think that
matter there wasn't really a serious
atomic theory of matter
until more like the 1800s and that came
in with people like dalton and so on and
what made that come in was getting more
serious about chemistry and getting more
quantitative about chemistry and
noticing that in chemical reactions
there were these uh integer ratios of
things you know you would get three
units of this made two units of that
there were there were sort of small
integers that showed up and that kind of
gave one the idea that well perhaps
what's happening is that there are
discrete units
of you know sulfur or whatever else it
is that isn't just a certain amount of
sulfur it's a certain number of atoms of
sulfur or molecules of this and that's
the counting of those things that led to
these kind of ratios in chemistry and
such like
and
it was it was kind of the the um
in the 1800s there was sort of this
almost i don't know people how seriously
people believed it that there was sort
of a a theory of chemistry that that
involved this let's assume there are
atoms we haven't ever seen them a little
bit like what happened with quarks and
elementary particles in the 1960s of you
know let's assume there are quarks even
though we haven't seen them
with atoms
uh i guess there was brownian motion
maybe 1830s or so maybe a little bit
later than that
um where a chap called brown
um
observed that if you put just pollen
grains very light things
in a liquid you would occasionally see
them being kicked around discreetly and
it's like how can this be
and the answer was well there are
discrete things and it is not the case
that the pollen grain is just sitting
there in this continuous fluid the fluid
consists of discrete things and
eventually it sort of became clear those
are those are really the atoms that have
been seen to be relevant for thinking
about sort of stoichiometry and
chemistry and so on and uh and so by the
by the end of the 1800s well but okay as
the atomic theory
got developed there were many details
like maxwell's work on the on you know
imagining you had a bunch of molecules
bouncing around and figuring out what
their velocity distribution would be
work on on thermodynamics boltzmann and
so on realizing that well you have this
configuration of molecules there's this
idea of them getting more random over
time boltzmann's equation things like
that that was all happening 1860s 1870s
those kinds of times and by
by
and so the atomic theory of mata was was
pretty well established then in 1900
planck noticed max planck noticed that
these phenomena and black body radiation
were sort of better understood by having
discrete quanta of light
and then einstein kind of cleaned that
idea up and introduced the notion of
photons so people had the idea there are
discrete
photons there are discrete atoms
of matter
there are then the idea of quantum
mechanics these discrete spectral lines
that were observed these other things
that were discrete the discrete spin of
a particle the discrete set of states
that an atom can be in these kinds of
things lots of discreetness
by the 1920s when quantum mechanics was
kind of really breaking out it was like
everything's discreet
and
people
uh had the the thought at that time
space will be discrete as well
i mean einstein for example in 1916 just
after he invented general arts holiday
the the theory of gravity
um
had this statement look in the end we're
going to discover that space is discrete
but he said we don't have the tools
mathematical or otherwise available
now to be able to understand things in
that way but so it was kind of an
assumption that space would turn out to
be discreet because everything seemed to
be turning out to be discrete matter
light
states of quantum systems all the street
so why wouldn't space be discrete
so
then people started working by the 1920s
early 1930s people were like space is
going to be discrete
and then they said oops there's a
problem
how does relativity work with a discrete
space how do you get because relativity
says things like you know if you have a
discrete space and you divided space up
into cells and then you have uh
lorentz contractions and things
in um uh as you're moving relative to
that discrete set of cells that's very
hard to understand and people tried to
do that in slightly more formal way they
tried to make a sort of theory of
discrete space that was compatible with
relativity and they didn't succeed and
so then people said well i guess space
isn't discrete everything else is
discrete but space isn't discrete let's
let's ignore that possibility
and and that was kind of how it was from
about the 1940s
through to
well really very recently
um people
uh had this idea
occasionally people would come up with
well maybe space's place is discreet i
think roger penrose in the 1950s not
early 1960s kind of had that sort of
thought maybe spaces to sweet i think
david finkelstein maybe a little bit
later had similar thoughts um
john wheeler
uh maybe had similar kinds of thoughts
people imagine well maybe it will turn
out to be somehow discreet but it wasn't
there were a few particular ideas for
how that might work but it was still
very much under the cloud of how will we
make it relativistically invariant how
will we make it compatible with with
special relativity forget even general
relativity and gravity how would we even
make it compatible with special
relativity and so people got the idea
that no space is the way euclid had said
it was which is sort of this background
in which you can just place things
wherever you want and it's not discrete
even though everything else is discrete
space and time not discrete now people
looked for discreteness in space and
time there were i remember in the 1970s
in particle physics people occasionally
would talk about the idea of maybe there
are pronons
discrete units of time
and what would happen what happened at
that time there were particles that were
extremely short-lived particles so
the particles that live 10 to the minus
23 seconds 10 to the minus 24 seconds
those are typical particles that decay
through the strong nuclear force through
kind of qcd type type processes
and um they fall apart super quickly and
people i remember when i was first
interested in particle physics in the
mid 1970s people were like plotting you
know what are the the lifetimes decay
widths
as they're called of these different
very unstable particles and do they
maybe cluster in a way where we can see
a cronon you know a unit of of um
uh
of time that is to sweep well they
didn't ever find anything
and people wondered about
uh was there
uh sort of
well in addition to the sweetness of
space another thing that was kind of
mysterious is things like electrons
electrons seem to have zero
intrinsic size something like a proton
it's got a size it's 10 to the minus 15
meters across it's full of all kinds of
gunk of quarks and gluons and so on but
an electron so far as people have known
is of zero size yes it has photons kind
of uh emitted reabsorbed around it that
kind of give it a kind of coat
that um but the intrinsic electron
that's in there seems to be of zero size
and to have a model of the electron that
isn't of zero size was a very
non-trivial thing although in a sense
that's been achieved by making models of
i mean it's still a bit messy but models
of of things like protons that are
non-zero size
but in any case that was another kind of
uh you know
in terms of what's discrete it's does
the electron have zero size or not back
in 1974 when i was first getting
interested in particle physics um in
fact my very first um paper about
particle physics had to do with the
possibility of non-zero size electrons
and the possibility that
on length scales of water like 10 to the
minus 18 meters
that electrons might be sort of a
thousand times smaller than a proton
that electrons might be of non-zero size
uh didn't work out for that length scale
um but it's that was sort of part of the
whole story people people looking for
discreteness in space
were also people were looking for sort
of finite sizes of non-zero sizes of
electrons not a lot of experiments done
on those things not a lot uh sort of
people had um
ideas about this but it wasn't taken
very seriously people just assumed space
is continuous that's just the way it is
we've got all this lovely mathematics
that works that way
now there's one corner of this story
that's sort of a weird corner which is
the sort of early computer science crowd
people like marvin minsky
um long time friend of mine ai pioneer
um
who um uh you know marvin would think
about physics from time to time and um
uh
marvin and other people like ed fredkin
and so on um who were sort of in the mit
ai orbit
um
the um
uh
they would have discussions uh i think
in the 60s and 70s mostly 1960s 1970s
about you know what if
the world was sort of set up like we set
things up on computers um then computers
are discreet so therefore the world must
be discreet
and then like one of the things that
that marvin
used to ask me about is but if there are
you know if it's all discrete like on a
computer what about round-off error in
the universe
so you know when you try and take a real
number the kind of thing that people
have developed in the in the 1800s in a
sort of formal way where you have a
number like you know pi
is this exact number that has an
infinite collection of digits well if
you try and represent it on a computer
not symbolically if you're trying to
represent it explicitly as digits on a
computer the computer is only going to
store a finite number of digits you can
still represent pi symbolically you can
say you know pi is the symbol in world
from language it's just the symbol pi
and if you say sine of pi it will say
zero and it knows that as a symbolic
matter that the sine of pi is zero it
doesn't just take a certain number of
digits and compute numerically what the
what the sine function is it knows
symbolically it can symbolically work
out that it's zero
but marvin
in in sort of a very computer sciencey
way even though marvin was trained as a
mathematician
marvin uh was kind of thinking
computerly
and was talking about well shouldn't the
universe if it's really kind of
computer-like have things like round off
error and it's like
no
i mean and not in any not in any real
the the way that that space i mean i for
a long time
was
was not
uh the the idea that space would be
discreet as it is in a cellular
automaton we just have a discrete
collection of cells or as you have it in
there's a chap called zuza who was an
early german computer pioneer who uh
built some slightly mysterious this is a
this is a rabbit hole let me not go down
this one today but maybe people can ask
about another time of uh the the
computer built in the 19 during world
war ii by by zuza and what happened to
it that's a whole whole interesting
story about whose end is not yet known
at least to me um but uh uh
khan azuza who who lived until the 1980s
actually i exchanged uh letters with him
and so on um was another person who who
sort of had this oh
you know computers are interesting space
must be somehow discrete
but his version of it was very much like
finite difference methods in solving
differential equations that is when you
are given here's the equations for fluid
mechanics they are written in terms of
derivatives with respect to space when
you put those on a computer you say well
we can't do a perfect derivative if
we're doing this thing numerically if
we're not doing it symbolically we have
to discretize space and just say the
fluid velocity is this at this point
this at the neighboring point and so on
and that was kind of his notion of of
how you would make space discrete um i
think that um
uh
in um
um
and so that that was that was kind of um
uh that idea but i think there was sort
of a
for me
the the sort of how could space be
discrete
it definitely wasn't a cellular
automaton i knew that from things that
people had figured out in the 1930s
1940s
that that just wasn't going to be
compatible with things we knew about the
structure of space time and so on and it
was early 1990s i got started thinking
about well what if space was made from
these networks where you just have
discrete sort of atoms of space related
by these networks
uh you have a different story from the
traditional story of sort of a discrete
space where you've got everything in its
own kind of lattice array type thing
and by the mid 1990s i i'd shown that um
that actually with with this kind of
setup of these networks you would get
relativistic invariants
another thing that was a little hard to
break out of was the following idea
uh in
back when einstein was first formulating
relativity uh sort of one of the big
points was
that you had to kind of rethink your
notion of both space and of time
and so herman minkowski for example
noticing einstein's kind of t squared
minus x squared is really the distance
measure that you should be looking at
minkowski had worked on quadratic forms
in number theory and said that's a
quadratic form we should be bundling
together space x variables and t timed
variables and thinking about these
quadratic forms as a single thing as the
single time space-time
coordinates space-time objects
and so that kind of got started with the
idea of space and time and really the
same kind of thing and there are lots of
kind of thought experiments which kind
of give you sort of indications of the
mixing of space and time which was a key
idea the relativity but the notion that
space and time really are sort of
fundamentally the same kind of thing was
the notion that by the by the 19 i don't
know 50s 60s that was deeply burnt into
the fundamental theories of physics that
what you really were dealing with was
space-time variables x mu
you know
momentum four momentum variables energy
momentum and so on that that well
particularly space and time really just
bundled into these four vectors three
dimensions of space one of time they're
all packaged together and to have
something where space and time were of a
different character seemed like
completely against the tide of physics
as it was going and so for example in
these models that i started developing
in the 1990s that have become our uh
physics project now
um one of the features of those models
is space is the extent of this
hypergraph
time is the progression the
computational progression of rewriting
of this hypergraph and at first it seems
like gosh these are making space and
time completely different kinds of
things what emerges through this idea of
causal graphs and so on is that actually
as an emergent matter space and time
behave the same kind of way just like
digital relativity and we can derive the
features of relativity it's a
non-trivial thing to be able to derive
those from something lower level but so
there was sort of a hold up there
because it kind of seemed like in
physics you package space and time
together but really that doesn't seem to
be true
so an interesting question now is can we
see the sweetness in space where would
we see it that's a hot question as far
as i'm concerned um i think there are
possibilities in rapidly spinning black
holes where we can kind of see the
almost disconnection of space-time in
this at this discrete level where we can
see things like
discrete
bursts of gravitational radiation
perhaps that come from the the discrete
character of of the underlying structure
of space-time um but it's really a very
interesting question
where can we make you know what is the
brownian motion
of discrete space time what is the thing
that gives you what is the experiment
you do that kind of gives you this
indication as little pollen grains and
liquids did that there's something
discrete here that space is not
continuous
it's it's one thing to have a theory in
which it's very convenient to say space
is not discreet it's kind of a
copernican kind of thing it's convenient
to say the earth goes around the sun but
it's like prove it um you know can you
are there effects that are that happen
because things are discrete there
certainly will be and there certainly
theoretically are the question is can
you actually uh bring those those
effects to a level where you can
identify an actual experiment that can
be done either astrophysical experiment
or a kind of particle physics type
experiment that can be done accessible
with today's technology where you can
see that distinction
so i i would say that the um
uh
for me
uh kind of
the
the question of is space not discrete is
really wrapped up with the question of
should the world be described with real
numbers or with integers
and the whole computational tradition of
turing machines and so on is all about
describing the world in terms of things
like integers
one of the things that was complicated
was
that for physicists
real numbers were the thing
and you know
turing machines
were okay that's a thing sort of about
the concepts of computing but when it
comes to physics people even alan turing
himself
thought
well actually differential equations and
real numbers they're what's going on so
in the 1980s when i started working on
applying ideas from computation theory
to physics
people were like but but but how can you
do that physics we know physics works
with real numbers it doesn't you know
computational theoretical ideas do not
apply to physics
and and that was something that you know
i was uh very much introducing those
kinds of ideas as a way to think about
things in physics and elsewhere in the
1980s but that was not what people
thought was going on it's been a gradual
process since then both as computers i
like to think that mathematica which
came out in 1988 has been a part of kind
of the the advance of computers as a as
a way of of doing practical theoretical
physics and so on but um uh and there's
sort of weaving computers into kind of
the fabric of how one deals with physics
but then things like enthusiasm for
quantum computing and so on which is
sort of a in some ways a reformulation
of kind of traditional quantum mechanics
but in a computational setting
some of these kinds of things have made
computation a more sort of attractive
concept mixed in with physics and so
that makes it a little bit less alien to
start talking about the idea of
computational kinds of constructs these
discrete things that are like the kinds
of things that show up in turing
machines being relevant to physics i
think at this point i have to say i am
without there's no doubt
that physics and space is ultimately
discrete
the actual length scale we do not know
we need we have one parameter if we can
only find one experiment that will
coming from all these different angles
of maximum entanglement speed in quantum
mechanics or elementary length or
elementary time or or elementary energy
any of these kinds of things if we can
get any of those if we don't experiment
in any of those areas we'll nail down
the value of this one parameter then
we'll be able to get all this other
stuff but as of right now we just don't
know what the elementary length might be
but that there is an elementary length i
think is really unquestionably the case
um and uh people yeah in talking about
you know in the attempts to do certain
quantum gravity people sort of vaguely
talked about well traditional quantum
mechanics versus gravity the planck
length
10 to the minus
43 seconds
10 to the minus 35 meters um must be uh
uh you know something must happen down
at that length scale discreteness
maybe
people that weren't really sure but
something must happen down there in our
models the where something happens is
probably much smaller lengths there's a
there's a sort of factor of maybe as
much as 10 to the 100 that is sort of
off in the traditional way of thinking
about where discreetness happens it has
to do with the whether once dealing with
all the parallel threads of of um of
history in quantum mechanics or other
ones homing in on one thread
that introduces another factor that
makes things like the elementary length
much smaller than the planck length
all right long answer to that
uh
let's see
ah
well
the um
um
let's see there's a comment from william
here
uh if space is discrete does that mean
the fundamental constants are rational
numbers so the most famous of those is
the fine structure constant about 1 over
137 that
determines the strength of
electromagnetic forces
um
the answer is that yes we absolutely
will be able to derive
those constants
from an intrinsic and underlying theory
but they will not be rational numbers it
would be extremely unlikely for them to
be rational numbers um because those
constants arise from various limits of
various things that are descriptions of
sort of structures that exist in
discrete space-time et cetera et cetera
et cetera it's like saying you know just
because there are discrete sum terms in
the sum of the series you know one over
one square plus two square plus three
squared et cetera et cetera et cetera
that that should be a rational number
it's not it's you know that particular
one i mentioned earlier it's pi squared
over six
but um uh the the fact that there is a
discrete underlying structure does not
mean it means that the constants should
be computable
that there should be some computational
procedure for generating them to
arbitrary precision whether there will
be a closed form formula something where
our mathematics can say it's the square
root of one plus the zeta function or
whatever i i actually rather doubt that
it will be something where in fact it's
almost certain that that's not the case
it's something where you say if you run
this computation long enough you will
get as many digits as you want of the
fine structure constant you know there's
a story
uh it's kind of a a bad story about
people with fundamental theories of
physics
um arthur eddington who was a
cambridge
sort of mathematical physicist
in the early part of the 1900s
was
well he had many many attributes but he
was a a um some ways a rather mystical
mystic thinking
kind of physicist
but um
uh he um
one of his famous things was that he um
uh led the expedition in 1919
which verified the bending of light
around the sun predicted by einstein's
theory whether whether he really did
that experiment well or whether he was
like we're going to get this answer
it was a time right after the end of
world war one when there was a lot of
sort of pressure i mean uh eddington had
been a pacifist in world war one and was
very much in the you know uh uh
you know let's let's let's be friends
with the people that we were at war with
type thing
um the uh and really wanted to have a
british expedition to south africa you
know validate the german scientist
einstein's
uh you know theories and i think there
was a certain degree of of kind of uh
of of sort of bias and we've really got
to verify this theory kind of thing and
i think the experiment probably wasn't
done that carefully um but uh
in the end it turned out it was just
fine and right but that was a place
where arthur ellington had sort of been
been famous there he was also a person
who wrote quite a lot of popular books
about about science and um
uh i think also about the relation
between science and religion and so on
um a bunch of different kinds of things
but he um
uh
he was some
uh he had a fundamental theory of
physics which was pretty hokey
um
and one of the things that went wrong
it's kind of a a bad story here
was um when he'd been making up his
theory the value of the fine structure
constant had been measured as about 1
over 136
and so
uh eddington had this whole theory that
was as i say
rather a hokey thing
that was a a sort of a fundamental
theory of physics in which he predicted
or postdicted that the fine structure
constant is 136.
all good all fine well then of course
the experiments change and it turns out
to be one over 137
and so famously eddington said oh whoops
we made a mistake in our calculations
you know we have to add one for the
trace of this matrix to make it 137.
that's a very unconvincing thing to do
if you're a theoretical scientist you
kind of have to go
and say we did the calculation and
whatever we say you know the experiments
will come in now the thing to be aware
of is those those calculations are often
really hard to actually get to the point
where you've built all the way from a
fundamental theory to something where
you can do an experimental measurement
and then you have to get the experiment
right having those two things merge
correctly is a very difficult thing and
i know in in my own life in particle
physics for example back in the 70s i
one case in particular i was was um
uh the the you know i had this
calculation which just didn't agree with
the experiments that had been done and i
kind of sort of wrote it down anyway
turned out in the end that calculation
was right i'd had another experience
where there were experimental results
that were
that in that case the theory was right
the experiment was wrong and subsequent
experiments kind of agreed with the
theory
but i'd had another experience where uh
experiments had revealed something very
unexpected and i'd sort of tried to
figure out can i come up with a theory
for this
it turned out that was all waste because
the experiments weren't right
um
okay let's see some other questions here
um
okay
ah
carob asks what stage in history did the
idea of extraterrestrial alien life
start to be entertained
you know i i don't remember all of this
history i remember looking at this um
the
you know i i think there was some
thought about this in antiquity but by
the time
there were the standard monotheistic
religions and so on there was like look
we humans are really special
we're here in the center of the universe
and
this idea of other worlds
is um
uh
um
is kind of a you know
that's that's not something we should
think about we are you know we are
unique
we are um and uh
and and there really aren't other things
like us but now i think giordano bruno
didn't he have a
who um was kind of viewed as a religious
heretic
um i think he had he had ideas about
other other worlds and so on and i think
this was sort of a thing that bubbled
around
uh you know in the time of people like
kepler 1600s
you know kepler was certainly talking
about the inhabitants of the moon
as a as a like well there's going to be
you know of course their inhabitants on
the moon you know we've explored
different parts of the earth you know
columbus you know
came to the new world so to speak and
found there were inhabitants of the new
world and of course their inhabitants of
the moon and i think they were even um
when was it some people were talking
about you know in the mountains of the
moon and people with caves and the in
the you know the inhabitants with with
the uh things there and it was it was
really a a kind of almost taken for
granted that there would be
uh for local things like the moon um
in uh
certainly when i was a kid it was still
very much up in the air whether there
were planets around other stars or
whether our solar system was somehow
special i think it really wasn't very
hard to imagine that there will be
exoplanets and of course now we know
zillions of exoplanets and having
planets around your star is a standard
thing not an exceptional thing
um i think that um uh this this idea
of um kind of um
uh you know there are
extraterrestrial intelligences out there
uh certainly
people like h.g wells
in the uh early part of the 1900s was
very much um you know the war of the
worlds and so on was a uh you know a
story about these um critters on mars or
from mars
um and uh that was thought to be you
know yeah sure you know why not type
thing so i think i think this this was a
thing that um
uh
uh
you know the idea of there being sort of
a a critters like us
on the moon even
was was pretty much a thing that was uh
had gone from being oh no that can't be
the case because we humans are so
special to something where it was kind
of like um uh i i suppose there's a
there's a difference here between sort
of uh you know people living on the moon
and the idea of very different sort of
alien intelligences or something out
there very different from humans i'm not
sure how those were knitted together but
i think in um
uh
by the time like in the in the 1960s
uh
the the idea that mars for example had
vegetation on it
was like yeah it was seemed like a
pretty plausible thing
and people noticed what we now know are
dust storms in the atmosphere of mars
they noticed that in different seasons
there would be different kind of
colorations in different parts of mars
and sort of the standard assumption was
oh that was vegetation kind of growing
and decaying in in um
through the martian year so to speak and
it was uh you know when spacecraft first
landed on mars in the 70s it was kind of
like okay we'll dig up pieces of the
soil and there's nothing obviously
hanging out down here um
and uh
and that was kind of a
that was almost a surprise at the time
i think this notion of of truly ex sort
of
extraterrestrial intelligence
at more of a distance you know different
stars things like that
that was the thing
that um
kind of
uh well okay so that there were
in the early days of radio people
started wondering well are we getting
radio emissions from the martians or
something like that i mean tesla
for example nikola tesla
um was uh kind of like yes the martians
are signaling us in radio
uh marconi for example early pioneer of
radio
was was famously you know had his yacht
that he went across the atlantic on and
in the middle of the atlantic you know
was had this radio mast and was was
hearing radio emissions and like where
are these coming from
turns out as we now know their their
features their ionosphere the earth's
ionosphere that's producing radio
emissions but although marconi i don't
think was big on the idea that those
must be the martians signaling us i
think tesla was big on that idea it's
like they're going to use radio we now
have radio it's in the new technology
you know they must be ahead of us and
they must be using radio and they must
be signaling things in in radio
i think
uh by
the um
around 1960
uh well there were physicists a chap
called coconi was one of them um
who uh and philip morrison was another
one involved in that
um who were interested in the
possibility what that was a time when
radio telescopes were first being
constructed and it was kind of like well
let's use these radio telescopes to try
and uh listen for radio emissions
from
uh you know distant civilizations and
frank drake famously kind of tried to
estimate well how many civilizations
would there be out there and enrico
fermi in the 50s was kind of like you
know this this where are they all you
know how can there be sort of this
paradox that there are so many stars and
yet uh there's there's nobody sort of uh
um there's nobody communicating with us
there's no uh intelligence uh like us
out there and and so i think this idea
this was a thing in the in the sixties i
would say that really got started this
kind of seti such extraterrestrial
intelligence notion of oh there might be
intelligence is out among the stars so
to speak
um i think at the beginning
people
were well i remember
in um the mid 70s
oh gosh what's the person's name
it's a person um
oh my gosh
chief scientist at hewlett packard uh
the time
bernard oliver i think something like
that
um my name memory is not perfect um
uh but i think that that was the
person's name bernie oliver yeah i think
that's the name the um uh was somebody
who was involved in sort of early
setting efforts and it's like let's just
construct the right bigger better
telescope and then we'll hear from those
extraterrestrial civilizations and it's
been kind of a gradual process of people
saying oh it's actually more difficult
than we expected oh we're not hearing
anything oh et cetera et cetera i mean
my own feeling about this is
that
uh what we've learned recently about the
physics project kind of gives us a bit
of insight about what's going on there
and just as you know we are at a
particular position in physical space
we live on you know this planet in this
galaxy et cetera et cetera
so in this notion of rulial space
the in the space of all possible
rules that we can attribute the behavior
of the universe that we can attribute to
the behavior of the universe
um we are living we are interpreting
things in terms of our particular
position in rural space
and in a sense the what i've come to
think
is that we are at this place in physical
space we're also at a certain place in
rural space we have a certain way of
interpreting what is intrinsically
happening in the universe we have a
certain way of kind of parsing the
structure of space what all those atoms
of space mean and so on and that way of
interpreting things
is as special
as our particular position in physical
space
and the fact that we haven't encountered
the the aliens so to speak
is because we're both separated in
physical space that doesn't happen to be
they don't happen to be presumably any
you know highly human civilized aliens
hanging out in our solar system
so similarly we're separated in rural
space
and in a sense those other
intelligence-like things
are are sort of
our their version of intelligence is
kind of interpreting the universe in a
vastly different way than we do and so
we don't get to recognize uh them so to
speak as sort of human-like
intelligences where we can just say oh
it's like
those uh you know those critters those
um you know human-like critters who are
living on the moon and those uh in the
caves and the in the shadow of the um of
the mountain the moon so to speak so you
know i think that's um uh but it's been
this very you know i suspect that's
my guess is that's really the main story
that there's plenty of kind of
intelligence-like stuff in the universe
it's just not well aligned with us in
rural space it's something where many
things have a mind of their own that's
something that comes out of this
principle of computational equivalence
of mine but
that mind is not a mind aligned with
kind of human ways of thinking it's not
something that we recognize as
intelligence or we even recognize
its way of perceiving the universe
well let's see
uh
the question from
pretty
when did we first realize that we see
the same side of the moon only
ah
interesting
i think
i don't know and i don't know what i
mean
certainly by the time the theory of the
tides was being thought about by by
newton for instance
um
i don't know whether whether newton
recognized
that
uh
i i don't think he did that tidal forces
on the moon would lock it in so that it
would have
uh you know one face pointing towards
the earth i i don't know the answer that
it's a good question i mean certainly by
the time
um
you know galileo 1608 was sort of using
a telescope to find mountains on the
moon so to speak um by that point
certainly people knew that the moon
always had one face pointed towards the
earth but i don't know
uh
i don't know
kind of uh the the locking of well okay
so vibrations of the moon the slight
deviation from the uh from the moon
actually having a fixed orientation with
respect to the earth
um those were known
those were probably known to galileo um
and
when people started really thinking
about that and the notion of solid tides
on the moon and tidal forces and so on
um
i would think that was known
i'm not sure
um certainly by the time
people like um
uh
charles darwin's son george darwin
was
developing the sort of elaborate theory
of the moon um that was the
latest 1800s
all of this stuff had been studied in
great detail but i don't know the answer
that good question
um
let's see maybe one or two more here
um
boy um
aaron asks how um
what belief systems or groups of people
have historically believed in a
fundamentally discreet universe
um
i don't know
i think
i don't
recall
creation myths being i mean there are
creation myths in essentially every
culture
and um you know from like
uh
you know there are
there are kind of explanations of how
the universe came to be
uh why it is the way it is and so on uh
they're actually very interesting in
many cases
of of kind of the way that people have
thought about
for example the relationship between the
naming of things
and the things themselves and so on it's
it's like uh you know and at this point
this name was given to this thing
and uh you know the the notion of a of a
thing existing independent of its name
and how the naming of it
has gives it certain reality and so on
it's sort of interesting philosophical
points but i i i don't know
i did do actually 25 years ago i did
quite a survey of creation myths um and
uh
the
i don't recall
i mean there's an awful lot of of
creation myths that start
in sort of random chaos
and then the order of the world is born
from that
um
it's and then there are you know
the creation myths where
you know the the world was created from
a giant coconut and things like this
um it uh i i don't recall ones where
the concept is that the world is made of
discrete things and and sort of as the
world forms all these discrete things
come together i i don't i don't recall
any of those i think they're much more
uh out of
some formless thing
there emerges a um uh sort of the
structure of the world out of something
kind of continuous but is an interesting
question i i don't know i'm i'm um
um
let's see there was a question here
about
maybe make this um
uh
from
okay that's interesting some unicode
characters that look like they might be
hindi
so i can't like no way i can read this
name three identical characters that's
all i can say um
the uh
why do i think the distribution of new
discoveries is so random commenting that
nassim taleb notes that there was 6 000
years between the invention of the wheel
and the idea of wheels on a suitcase
well let's talk about wheels on
suitcases for a second
you know i remember when i first saw
people with wheels on suitcases and i'm
like that's a cool idea i want to get
one of those um and that must have been
in the what
uh late 70s early 80s um and you know it
was firstly flight crews for commercial
planes and things would have these and
and it's like um now why did that take
so long i think the reason is because
the engineering is not quite as simple
as you might think
to make a you know a nice hard plastic
wheel that won't be destroyed and has
you know axles that that work and so on
on a suitcase
was just not quite as easy as you might
think and i think probably initially
they were quite expensive and only
people who like use their suitcase every
day wanted to go to the extra expense of
getting these elaborately engineered
things so i think it wouldn't be quite
fair to say that i mean it's quite often
the case that inventions require ambient
engineering changes i mean one might
have said
oh what what about you know the the
phone camera for example you know why
couldn't i mean but the idea that there
will be phone cameras and phones that's
a um
uh
philippe khan was the person who who
came up with that idea which at first
seemed just completely bonkers um and
then of course we we um we realized that
it's a very convenient thing because you
want you don't want to have a camera and
a phone separately you've got your phone
in your pocket just get it out but but
the possibility of doing that was a
consequence of miniaturization of of
cameras and lenses and ccd
uh you know et cetera et cetera et
cetera and it's not something where one
could have said well you know let's put
like imagine the phone
like the att you know
uh
well you know the early bakelite phones
of you know early plastic things with
their definite shapes and the things
where you would you know pick up the
receiver separately from the um
from the mouthpiece and all those kinds
of things they say well why can't we
have a phone camera at that point would
be completely crazy at that point the
technology the ambient technology
had not reached the point where that
could be sensibly conceptualized and i
think that's a a pretty common thing
that sort of there's a progressive sort
of development of technology
and then at some moment something
becomes possible and then you can have
the conceptual idea to have that
particular invention
now i think that
it is an interesting question what
inventions are out of their time what
inventions were surprisingly slow to get
made or surprisingly fast to get made
what inventions did people kind of
imagine you know leonardo da vinci
people might say was sort of imagining
helicopters and so on but clearly the
ambient technology did not exist in the
1500s 1400s to to create a helicopter
and so
you you're kind of that's a thing
imagined out of its time
and i think that the um uh this
this notion of
i mean there is a certain main thread of
development of sort of ambient
technology and ideas
that seems to be the sort of inexorable
uh kind of progress and one can
characterize that progress
as it's kind of a supply chain story of
a sort of you know first you can make
this and then based on that once you can
make lots of that you can then make this
using that etc etc etc and that happens
both for physical things people make and
for ideas it's hard to have certain
kinds of ideas without having built up
this sort of infrastructure underneath i
mean one of the ones that's been a long
time favorite of mine is could universal
computation have been invented in the
1600s or earlier i think the i think the
answer is probably yes that's probably
an idea uh delayed by past it's past the
time it needed to be delayed on the
other hand
it's not obvious that people would have
understood the significance of it at all
and that um uh you know these things
even if it is technically possible if
there isn't the context for it it's like
you you come up with this thing and
nobody knows what to make of it i mean i
would say that quite a lot of the things
i've invented in my life are things
where in a hundred years people will say
oh yeah you know that all fits in you
know we understand why that's that is
the way it is i think it's a it's a
challenge sometimes there are things you
invent which as as one person trying to
build sort of a tower of ideas you can
get to the top of that tower and you can
see quite a long way
but as something where there's sort of
ambient knowledge where those ideas all
fit together that may not happen for a
long time a lot longer
and so that's um
that's another thing but but i kind of
think that um
uh you know when it comes to
these sort of um
that there are the kind of
ideas
that
sometimes
you will have the situation there's sort
of this ambient building of capabilities
that can happen both societally in
general and it might happen in
individual people or small groups of
people
where you can build a certain tower and
when you you know having built that
tower you can get to the next you know
major
thing probably not a suitcase with
wheels it's probably not a major thing
to have got to but um uh
it's um
yeah so i mean i i i think
and the pattern tends to be
when you get one of those major things
it is either a
you know an invention a a a conceptual
advance a new paradigm for things then
there's all this low-hanging fruit that
gets picked and then that becomes a time
when you really notice that that thing
got invented because there's all this
stuff that is coming in along with that
but i'm not sure that's uh
um
um
yeah i mean you know people
you know i i will say there's another
another thing that people often talk
about they say you know people have said
i don't know 100 years ago they said all
discoveries that are going to be made
have already been made people say now
uh you know
uh well whose quote is it you know i was
i was expecting flying cars and all i
got was twitter type thing um maybe
that's peter tl's quote i'm not sure
um but uh
uh you know people say look the pace of
invention has slowed down but you know
almost always the reason people are
saying that is the following that there
is a certain pattern of how what kinds
of things have been invented and how one
is doing things and people look at that
pattern and they see there is a field
which was very very active let's say 100
years ago
20 years ago whatever
and
then the low hanging fruit of that field
got picked but that's the thing people
are focusing on you know for example the
very typical thing is there are prizes
that get given for field x
when when nobody described molecular
biology there wasn't a prize for
molecular biology it's always it's
always an irony that the people who
really start fields never win prizes for
them because there wasn't a prize for
the field when it was actually started
and so you know it's kind of interesting
if those people are sort of still alive
when the prizes roll in
what really happens because it's such a
weird thing that it's you know the prize
for field x
but the inventor of field x doesn't you
know it doesn't feel right that the
inventor of field x gets the prize for
field x because that's people doing
things in field x
so it it can be the case that once
there's a prize for a field the field is
you know it's a well-established field
the the great invention is probably over
you know there's lots of incremental
important things that have to be done
but the really you know the definitive
field forming inventions already done
and so if you say well look you know
let's look at what prizes people get for
this so let's look at what kinds of
prizes you know what what kinds of
things prizes are given in this field oh
it's all getting kind of boring
so that field must be dead well you
might be right that particular field has
had its low-hanging fruit picked but the
place where there's real innovation is
the new field maybe it doesn't even have
a name yet it certainly doesn't have a
prize yet and so that's that's the thing
that is sort of the the the
the insidious aspect of saying what's
new in the world what's new in the world
maybe things that don't even have names
yet and so you can't you don't think to
focus on them it's like well you know
there was a time when startups were the
bringers of of all things that were new
so to speak in the world and then
startups became more routine and it's
like gosh i'm looking at 100 startups
and they're all doing kind of the same
type of thing of you know making the
social network for dogs the so the you
know the the uh you know just
disintermediating this
this uh industry et cetera et cetera et
cetera i mean
it's kind of um uh but that's once
there's a thing once there are you know
the
the 20 different incubators that are all
churning out startups once there are
classes about how to make a startup
things like this
then
that that becomes a place where it is
not the highest innovation area of
what's happening in the world and if you
focus on the things that are describable
then you need
needless to say you end up concluding
that there is less and less innovation
but that's not in fact true because
there's innovation it just doesn't yet
have this kind of definition that was
the thing you used to focus on you know
let's count let's say
let's count the number of i don't know
uh
patents let's count the number of this
that and the other well then it turns
out yes that area gets to be rather
mundane after a while but there's some
new area you know let's count uh you
know
we're counting patents okay we really
should count icos you know initial coin
offerings for cryptocurrencies or
something oh no now you know let's not
count that we really should be counting
something else
the the thing that hasn't yet sort of
the thing that is just forming is the
place of highest innovation and we may
not be able to count anything there
because there isn't a thing that has
been well enough to find to counter it
and so it's hard then to assess you know
what innovation is happening and people
on the one hand i i have some friends
who would say you know
innovation is exponentially accelerating
and other people who i have sort of uh
uh
uh
i think it'd be fair to say sort of
equal respect for who say um uh you know
innovation has just come to an end
and it's like how can you come to these
two conclusions well you can say for
example the number of patents is
increasing the number of academic papers
is increasing you can also say the
content per paper is decreasing
and you know where does that land in the
end and are either of those things
actually useful measures of sort of the
rate of innovation i tend to think not i
think the rate of innovation is sort of
almost by definition the thing that you
can't yet measure well anyway um all
right we should probably uh
wrap up here
and um
uh
the um
um
um
uh
yeah maybe one one comment that um
um
that i might make about
the sort of the fact that we know more
than we did in the past
it's uh i think maybe i mentioned this
before but something i've i've wondered
about
is we know so much more
and
does that mean that
it is impossible to know
a broad spectrum of things about the
world and about science and so on and
you know i myself have spent a lot of
effort trying to have or have sort of
perhaps unwittingly um ended up knowing
about lots of different areas of science
and the question is can one wrap one's
arms around the whole thing so to speak
or is that something which oh yeah we
could do that in a renaissance
it's it's long past the time one could
do that
i think the thing to realize is that
abstraction
the turning of details into principles
is what makes that not impossible
that is that at a time you know in the
renaissance let's say
no doubt when people were studying i
don't know things in natural history
there were all these different critters
and all these different oh it has a this
kind of
mandible and this kind of antenna and
this this and this and lots and lots of
detail and then that all eventually gets
subsumed in one principle
about
how some area of natural history works
or whatever else or what people were
saying there are all these different
things in the sky and then we realize
well actually there's just one idea of
celestial mechanics and so on um and so
i think this notion of of uh sort of how
does with the advance with just more and
more things being known
uh mo you know how does one end up with
sort of only a finite amount of stuff to
learn and the answer is there are more
principles there's more abstraction and
that's a progression where these things
where you know lots of details and then
they get all sort of pulled together in
some abstract concept some principle of
conclusion um that's how one has the the
possibility one shouldn't give up just
because there's you know thousands of
linear feet of books about some
particular field it doesn't mean that
you can't kind of wrap your arms around
it um uh the it's it's uh
the fact that there are many details
known does not mean that you can't sort
of uh have principles that allow you to
kind of understand in in
the field and that's part of the
progress is is finding those principles
all right we should wrap up here um and
uh
um
thanks for um lots of interesting
questions and i see there are many more
that i did not get to today um and hope
to be able to
address them another time you know one
of the things i i i do these um
uh
these
sessions purely
you know look at the camera use my
memory and um sometimes i'm like really
i should look that up and and study it
in more detail i i've i've studied quite
a lot of history where i really i i like
to look at kind of the primary documents
and really go and dig in and try to
really understand how things worked um i
think one of my meta conclusions is
doing history is actually pretty hard
and you know to get it right is hard and
people particularly from science have a
terrible habit of just sort of
picking
the um
the oh it must obviously be this this
and this and actually when you look at
it it's a much more complicated story um
but uh
i'm i'm learning that you're supposed to
uh
um
uh pitch things you've done so i will
say that i've written a lot of stuff
about history where i've really
studied it in great detail where i'm i'm
i'm think i've kind of drilled down to
the level of sort of primary information
and can be can be very certain about it
and you can find that on my writings
website you can also there's a book i
put out few years ago called idea makers
which probably needs a a um a second
volume sometime soon because i've
written a lot of other stuff of
historical biographies of people and so
on
um but uh
that's those are those are things to
comment on i tend to when i write things
about different areas i just wrote a big
piece about the physicalization of
matter mathematics
um huge topic it's a 250 page
well some people might call it a blog
post but i think it's a it's kind of
transcended the um uh that by the time
it's 250 pages long but um that has a
that has a history section although it's
not in as much detail as some of the
other history sections that i've written
um but uh just just recommending some
some things i've written which uh where
where i where if i say i don't know
in the thing i've written it's because i
really investigated it and tried to
drill down to everything that was
knowable and found out one didn't know
um as opposed to what i'm doing here
where i i have to rely on my memory to
uh to to know things
anyway thanks very much for joining me
and uh see you again um
uh for this
uh series in two weeks
and um actually i have another live
stream in my my day job coming up in
just a couple minutes here
and um uh
we also have um most fridays
i do a science and technology q a for
kids and others this friday in uh in a
sign of the ending of pandemics um i'm
i'm actually traveling and i might i
might do this remotely possibly even
with a live audience we'll see
um uh that's will be coming up in a
couple of days
all right